so i became a landlady started taking in
people to
help my rent and this helped with your
but the homeless people you took and
they weren't helping with rent
well that's not exactly true so what
happened was i lost a tenant at the last
minute right
and i heard about a program which is a
rapid rehousing program
which is actually going on in 11 cities
around the country now
uh where you uh take in people
experiencing homelessness
young people and uh you get a stipend a
small stipend i mean no one's getting
rich
doing this you're not getting to the top
one percent but it's by doing
just you know every bit helps you know i
thought it would be better than nothing
and
you know i when i first heard that
phrase i just want to say
unhoused or experiencing homelessness i
thought
okay is this the new pc thing but
really when you look at who is slipping
in and out of homelessness in america
really accurately describes us we're
talking about
teachers right living in their cars
we're talking about young people one out
of four community college students
have housing instability in the whole
country
so this is a condition and yeah and you
became
kind of close to these people i mean at
first it seemed like
obviously i thought they were going to
murder me right i was worried they were
going to murder me in my sleep
but that's because i didn't understand
who was housing insecure
so you know they they they're coming to
my house and i want to be
nice and friendly but i'm hiding my
jewelry my mother's silver
in the closet and uh they get to my
house and they just start doing very
suspicious things
they start cooking salads they start
darning
socks they're reading they're calling
their mothers
and honestly bill that blew my mind
because
i didn't imagine i had you know words
they were normal people
they were normal people they had people
and in fact and in fact i was so
convinced that they were sketchy
you know that i at some point i thought
okay i'm gonna put their names into a
background
search and i've never had any experience
doing that so i put my name
in too and it turned out i was the
person who was flagged
i was the sketchy person in the house
right yes yeah
you